- I'm the queen of the world!
Yes!
I feel invincible!
Like I have super powers
or something! (laughs)
You hear that all you
(bleeps) of the world?
I can do anything I want
and no one can stop me!
(upbeat music)
- [Amy] He does talk,
like, you're listening.
- [Meegan] Yeah, oh, my God.
- [Amy] Do you know what I'm saying?
- [Meegan] Last time I
was like, "Who are you?
"You're brilliant!"
- [Amy] I know.
- [Meegan] Shut up.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, oh my god!
- (gasps) Oh, my god!
Oh, my god!
- Oh my god, Amy!
Oh, look at that one!
- Oh, Meegan, that is--
- [Meegan] He is so cute!
- That is the cutest effing puppy
I've ever seen in my entire life!
- Oh, my god, I'm just gonna take him
and I just wanna bite his little ears off!
- I just wanna take his
little legs and just, like,
snack on 'em like little,
like chicken drumettes!
- Yes!
I just want to take his
fuzzy little perfect head
and I want to put it in my mouth
and squeeze down on it hard
until I have a puppy-faced
diamond in my mouth.
- Mm!
I feel like I have to
wrap his face in a towel
and then beat it with a tire iron.
- I'm going to buy that dog.
- Mm-hmm.
- I'm going to drive him to the vet,
and I'm going to have
him put down immediately.
- (gasps) Look at him!
Oh my god, you know what
I'm gonna have to do?
- What?
- I'm gonna have to take
that scruffy little nose...
- Yes!
- And just kick it.
I just have to...
- Yes!
- I would kick it until
it comes off on my shoes.
- Yes!
- Like little puppy snout
slippers, you know what I mean?
And then I'm gonna go to a
party and everyone's like
"Oh my god, where'd you
get those slippers?"
And I'd be like "These?
- Yes!
"These are my face
slippers from my adorable
"dumb little puppy."
- That's exactly what I was going to say!
- Yes, B!
- Oh, my god, I just
wanna take his head...
- Mm-hmm.
- And I want to peel the
skin off of his skull.
- I know where you're going.
- And I just want to start
throwing it up like pizza dough.
- Mm-hmm.
- Until it's long, flat, and round.
- And I want to take it to a picnic
and toss it around like a Frisbee
in a puppy faced Frisbee picnic!
- Let's get him!
- Yeah!
(tense music)
- So cute.
- So cute!
Oh, my god, is it me or is it like
totally mosquito-y out here?
- Oh, my god, remember this one?
He was so cute!
- So cute!
(dramatic music)
- [Amy] So I'm doing this,
like, airline food diet.
- Yeah.
- It's like, all I eat and
I've lost, like, 16 pounds.
- Oh, my god, Amy, I
almost forgot to tell you.
- What?
- We got a new receptionist at work.
- Ew, no way!
- Yeah.
So, I'm in the common area,
alone, minding my own business.
- Yeah.
Oh, she said something to you?
- She came up to me and,
no joke, she's like,
"Hi, I'm Sandy.
"I don't believe we've met yet."
- (gasps) She said that to you?
- Like, no, Amy, I'm not even
kidding you, she's crazy.
- Um, yeah!
- No, like, I'm scared, like, crazy,
like, get this bitch away from me,
she's sociopathically batshit crazy.
- Oh, my god, that totally reminds me.
I have a new neighbor.
- Ew, yeah?
- She comes over my house,
she knocks on the door
with like, a package under her arm.
- Um, stalker much?
- Um, yeah!
And she looks me in the
eye and she says to me,
"Um, excuse me, I think the
postman dropped this package
"off at my house by accident."
- (gasps) She said that to you?
- Yeah!
- Crazy bitch!
- I mean, like, I'm gonna have to move
because this bitch is
Nutburgers McLooney Tunes,
stand-at-the-foot-of-my-bed-with-a-knife
crazy.
- Oh, my god, that totally reminds me!
- Oh, yeah?
- You remember that girl at Starbucks?
- The crazy one?
- No, a different one, she's new.
- I haven't met her yet.
- Well, she's crazy.
- Uh-huh?
- She gives me my change
and then she's like,
"Thanks, bye."
- (gasps) She smiled at you like that?
- How crazy is that?
- That's like, that's like,
insane in the membrane crazy.
Like, this is the membrane,
she's inside of it,
'cause that's insane.
- No, like, I'm not even kidding you, Amy,
that's crazy like "it puts
the lotion in the basket
"or else it gets the hose again"
cray to the mother (bleeping) cray!
- Yeah, like if JAY-Z had a
sister, her name would be CRAY.
- Hey!
(tense music)
You ladies want to meet Channing Tatum?
(both gasp)
- Is he really in there?
- Are you serious?
Oh, Channing!
- [Amy] Oh, my god, Channing!
- [Meegan] Channing, what
are you doing in a van?
- [Amy] This is effing crazy!
I don't see you, Channing,
why are you hiding?
- [Meegan] Why are you in here?
- [Amy] Channing, are you
like in a little ball?
Hello?
- [Meegan] It smells like mildew in here.
Ow, sharp, jagged rusty edge!
- [Amy] Is that a meat hook?
(suspenseful music)
(Andre laughing)
- God, the moment I saw
you last night at the club,
I totally had to ask you out.
- Are you kidding me?
Like the moment?
- Oh, yeah.
- That's so sweet.
- I was actually afraid
that you were gonna be like,
one of those high
maintenance chicks, you know?
- What?
- Yeah, oh, yeah.
Uh, I don't know, I don't
know, control freak or,
I don't even know, I don't even know.
- Oh, my god, that's so funny.
- Isn't it?
(laughs) Isn't funny?
Isn't it funny?
- No, I'm like, I totally just like to be,
just, like, easygoing.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Hi, I'm Wynn, I'll be your--
- It's been five minutes
and we're just now getting our menus?
(tense music)
- Oh, I'm sorry.
- Don't be sorry.
Be better.
(tense music)
- Right.
Okay, I'll be better.
- At your job.
Thank you.
(pop music playing)
So, yeah, my philosophy
is pretty much, like,
keep it chill.
- Right, yeah.
Yeah.
- You know what I like about you?
- No, what?
- It's like, you're
not afraid to be, like,
brainy and respectful.
- Right.
Thanks.
I really like your boobs.
(Meegan laughs)
- I think we really
complement each other well.
- We just did it right there.
- And, uh, I pretty much go with the flow.
- Right, right.
- And what the (bleep) is wrong with you?
- Excuse me?
- Do I look like Mad Max to you?
- I'm sorry?
- Do I look like Mel Gibson with a mullet?
- I...
No, not...
Not at all--
- Does he look like a feral child
with a boomerang in his hand?
- No.
- Then why the (bleep) is
water a rare commodity here?
- It's not,
it's not, I'm just, uh--
(Meegan laughs mockingly)
I'm sorry, I'm just really slammed, uh--
- No, you'll know when you're slammed
because your nuts will be on the table
and my fists will be
covered in your blood.
(tense music)
(pop music playing)
- Um...
You were, uh,
like, kinda harsh to that guy.
- Oh, him?
- Yeah.
- No.
I was a hostess at a restaurant.
In the industry, that's
how we talk to each other.
I'll show you.
Hey!
- Oh, God.
- Uh, hey.
(tense music)
- What do you see there?
- That's your water.
- No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Down.
- Down?
- Down, boy.
Get on your knees.
- Okay, I have other tables that I have...
- What does that look like to you?
- Yes, there is a little
lipstick on your glass.
- Okay.
- But it...
- Meegan it's your, it's your--
- This is what I want you to do.
I want you to take this
glass into the back.
I want you to break it.
Take the biggest shard you
can find and bring it to me.
- I'm...
- Then I'm gonna slit your gullet.
- All right, I'm just, I'll
get you another water--
- I'm gonna slit your throat
and watch you bleed out.
And I'm gonna shower in your blood.
- All right, I'll...
I'll get another water.
- Well, that would be great, thank you.
But as I was saying, like,
I just feel like it's like do unto others.
- Meegan!
It was your lipstick on the glass.
(tense music)
What the hell is that?
What are you doing?
Wait.
Wait a minute, no, no, no, no.
- Oh, my god.
Can I just tell you,
no one's ever talked to
me like that in my life.
- I'm just saying that your lipstick--
- You!
- I wasn't--
- Have his back?
Who does that?
- It was your lipstick on the glass!
- He's just a waiter.
You know what, take his side.
I hope you have a very
happy life together.
- Look, Meegan,
what's going on right now?
What are you do--
("Run Away" by Circuit
Shaker and Al Hilali)
Seriously, Meegan--
- No!
- No.
Meegan!
You left your jacket!
- Hey.
- You left your jacket!
- Hey, hey.
Don't do it.
- Man, I just hurt her feelings
and then she left her jacket.
The least I can do is
get her back her jacket.
- Don't do it.
Don't do it.
- She (bleeping) needs this jacket.
- She does not need it,
it's 87 degrees out.
You know she doesn't need it.
In your heart of hearts,
you know she doesn't need that jacket.
Don't do it.
- She's gonna need her jacket.
- No, she's not--
- Meegan, you need your jacket, though!
("Run Away" by Circuit
Shaker and Al Hilali)
- Seemed like a nice guy.
(dramatic music)
(movie characters speaking indistinctly)
- I'm going to the bathroom.
- Okay.
- 'Scuse me.
'Scuse me.
- Meegan, quiet down.
- 'Scuse me.
- [Andre] Meegan, you're being loud.
- Shh.
- And...
'Scuse me.
(dramatic movie music)
(movie character speaking indistinctly)
- (quietly) Meegan.
Meegan.
Meegan, what are you doing?
- Andre?
- Meegan.
- Andre, where are you?
- Shh!
- You shh.
I'm looking for my boyfriend.
- Better check your girl.
- Okay, right, I'm doing
it right now, dude.
Meegan!
- Andre!
- Meegan!
- Shh!
- Don't shh me!
- [Andre] I'm shushing you!
- [Meegan] Andre!
- Meegan.
- Andre!
- [Andre] Meegan.
- [Meegan] Andre!
- Meegan, come here.
- Andre?
- Meegan.
- Andre.
- [Andre] Meegan.
- Meegan.
- [Meegan] Andre.
- Meegan!
- Andre!
- [Audience Member] Shh!
- (quietly) Why would you go
back to where you were before?
(phone bleeps)
- Siri, call Andre.
- (whispering) Don't call me.
Don't do that.
Meegan.
(phone chiming)
(bleeped)
I'm sorry, I'm sorry,
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Meegan, what is wrong with you?
What the (bleep) are you doing?
- [Meegan] Andre, where are you?
- (whispering) I'm behind you.
- Will you FaceTime me?
- (whispering) I'm not
gonna do it right now.
You wouldn't be able to see me,
it's (bleeping) dark in here!
- I know, that's why I can't find you.
- (whispering) I'm directly behind you.
Turn around.
- [Meegan] Okay, I'm gonna turn around.
- (whispering) You didn't need
to announce it, just do it.
I'm right there.
(bleeping repeatedly)
- Stop yelling at me!
- Meegan, have you sustained a head injury
or had a stroke in the last 10 minutes?
- What do you mean by that?
- Meegan!
- Dude, put your phone away.
- Yup.
Yup.
- OMG, did you just hang up on me?
- Yes.
- I'm not talking to you, sir,
I'm talking to my boyfriend.
- It's me, Meegan!
- [Meegan] Andre!
- [Projectionist] Lady, get out of here!
- No, you get out of here.
I can go wherever I want,
I'm looking for my boyfriend.
Andre!
- [Projectionist] Come
on, you can't be up here.
- [Meegan] Andre!
Sh!
Get off me, mister director!
- He's not the director.
- Can you shine this
light on the audience?
I want to see my boyfriend.
Let me see something.
Ah!
The light's in my eyes!
- Meegan get out of the projection booth!
- [Audience Member] Shh!
- Don't shush me!
'Scuse me.
(dramatic movie music)
And...
'Scuse me.
(dramatic movie music)
I couldn't find the bathroom.
(sucks straw)
- [Andre] (sighs) Can you totally chillax?
- No, I'm so annoyed right now.
Can you like, not talk
to me for like a second?
Like, that'd be great.
That'd be fine.
That'd be fine by me.
What?
Oh, my god, are you serious?
This is bull (bleep).
What could possibly be the problem
with letting two more people in?
- Check your girl, bro.
- (sighs) I'm sorry.
- Excuse me, what did you say?
"Check your girl?"
Uh-uh, it doesn't work like that.
No one checks me because
I'm not luggage, okay?
So you can go (bleep) yourself.
- Meegan, seriously.
Two more people are gonna come
out in a couple of seconds
and then we can go in.
- No!
Let me ask you a question.
What was it like being
in "The Green Mile?"
- He wasn't in "The Green Mile."
He clearly wasn't in that movie.
- What does Tom Hanks's penis feel like?
- Meegan!
- Moreover, how does it
feel when swarms of bees
are coming out of your face?
- Seriously, I'm sorry, it's
like her favorite movie.
- Don't apologize for me!
Yeah, this is nice, this is nice.
You look like Common
meets the Incredible Hulk.
- Meegan--
- When you brought the
frankincense to Baby Jesus,
did they, like, make you
stand outside the barn
because you were too big
or did they invite you in
with all the other animals?
Don't flare your nostrils at me, okay?
- Please...
- Do you have any idea
how impolite that is?
- He hasn't moved his nostrils
once since we got here.
- I saw them move!
- They did not move, Meegan!
- They flared!
- Meegan they (bleeping) did not move!
- Your nostrils flared
more than a survivor
from a boat accident.
- What?
- He's not even looking me in the eyes.
Okay, you know what?
If you're just going to
continue to be a little prick,
you're gonna get your ass kicked.
- Don't touch him.
Meegan.
- (scoffs) Crazy bitch.
(Meegan gasps)
(Meegan exclaims)
(Andre sighs)
- Oh!
- I totally love my nails right now.
(dramatic music)
I'm so over everything right now.
I'm over the floor, I'm
over the sky, I'm over you.
I'm over that pussy back there.
You're a pussy!
- Meegan, seriously.
- Whatever.
(man smooching)
(man laughs)
Um...
Excuse me?
- Oh, God.
- Hey!
What did you say?
What the (bleep) did you just say?
You guys come back here with
your little itty bitty dicks.
- You best control your lady.
- Yep.
- (gasps) Excuse...
Control your lady?
No.
He doesn't control me.
'Cause let me tell you something,
I'm not a remote.
- Meegan, baby, can we just let this go?
- No, I'm talking to the
Pussies of Anarchy right now.
- Oh, boy.
- Yeah, you.
Why don't you all gather yourselves
and why don't you just
go and figure out a way
to (bleep) on each other's leathery penii?
- Hey, (bleep) you, bitch!
(Meegan gasps)
- Oh, Lord.
(Meegan exclaims)
(Andre sighs)
That's not even the plural of penis.
(punches landing)
- [Biker] Yeah!
- I'm the queen of the world!
Yes!
I feel invincible!
Like I have super powers
or something. (laughs)
You hear that all you
(bleeps) of the world?
I can do anything I want
and no one can stop me!
- That's because you don't
have to fight your own fights,
you crazy bitch!
(Meegan gasps)
Oh, boy.
(Meegan exclaims)
Oh, no.
(Andre sighs)
Ah!
(Andre thuds)
- Nothing can stop me!
(dance music pumping)
- [Andre] Are you kidding me?
- No!
- Seriously, you've got to
come back to the bar right now.
- You come back to the bar!
- Meegan, I don't even
(bleeping) know Claire!
- Yeah, right!
- I'm sorry!
You left your jacket.
- Yeah, well, why don't you give it to
your new fat, ugly girlfriend?
- All right, I never even met her yet!
- Whatever!
- You left your jacket, Meegan!
- Oh, throw it in a river!
- Why would I (bleeping) do that?
- I don't care, I'm over it!
- Fine!
God!
Meegan!
- Leave me alone!
- But your jacket, though!
- [Meegan] No!
- Seriously, Meegan!
- You start buying drinks for everybody
as soon as she comes over?
I mean, who does that?
- Meegan, come back to the bar!
- You're literally an asshole!
- How is that possible?
I can't be an asshole, I got
arms and legs and a head!
- Where's my jacket?
- I have your jacket!
- Fine!
- Do you want it?
- No!
- You know...
- Eat it!
- Why would I do that?
You know what?
I'm not following you anymore!
I'm done!
- Fine, I'm over it!
- Fine!
Meegan, come back to the bar.
- No!
- Meegan!
- [Meegan] Uh-uh!
- [Meegan] No!
- [Andre] Meegan!
- [Meegan] Uh-uh!
(ship's horn blowing nearby)
- Meegan!
Do you want your (bleeping) jacket?
- No!
- (sighs) Seriously, come back to the bar.
- You go back to the bar!
- I'm gonna throw this
jacket in the water.
- Oh, nice!
That's really nice.
- What do you want me to do, Meegan?
Damn!
- Kiss my butt-hole, okay?
- Good, fine, fine!
Then I'm going, I'm leaving right now.
God damn it!
Meegan!
- No!
- Like, seriously, your jacket!
- But it's your jacket, though!
- Whatever!
(dramatic music)
- Meegan!
- No!
Ah!
- I have your...
I have your jacket.
- I'm over it!
(Meegan thuds)
- Seriously, Meegan.
(birds cawing nearby)
(tense music)
- So what do you want to do tonight?
Like, I was thinking
maybe we could meet up
with Amy and Brad and, like,
before that we could go to Angelo's
and before that, we
could, like, just go buy--
- Meegan!
I have something to say.
(Andre exhales)
I had to say it in person.
Because it's...
It's like, super important.
- Okay.
- Um...
I know this is sudden,
but, like, I've been thinking
about this for a while.
And I know this is something
that needs to happen.
I'm breaking up with you.
- Cool, love it.
Totally fine with that.
- (stammers) Really?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I thought...
I just, I was really worried
that you were gonna be like, mad.
- Mad?
Oh, my god, are you kidding me?
No, of course I'm not mad.
People grow apart, it happens.
It's like, part of life.
No, I'm totally fine.
Like, love it, love it, love it.
- Um... (clears throat)
So...
Uh, um...
You know, we had a good run.
Yeah.
(gentle music)
Yeah, don't be a stranger.
Yeah.
- Can I just...
Can I ask why?
- Why?
- Yeah, like, whatevs, like,
I'm doing some work on myself
and like, trying to
grow as a person, so...
- Cool, cool.
- I'd really, like,
appreciate to know why.
- Yeah, um...
Okay, yeah, that's, like,
you know, I think that
you're kind of like,
a controlling person who--
- Thank you.
Thank you for that.
That's nice.
- Cool, no problem.
- [Meegan] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- So you know what your problem is, Andre?
- What?
- You keep tabs on people.
Every little thing somebody does,
you have to keep a tab of it.
- Wait, I, I...
I can't tell if you're angry or not.
- I'm not.
I'm totally not angry.
- [Andre] Oh.
- No, I'm excited, it's good.
It's just, like, you said your piece.
- Mm-hmm.
- And I just think that I
deserve the human decency
to say my piece.
- Right, right.
- Is that...
Is that not okay, or...
- No, no, no, it's...
No, of course, of course.
- You're a controlling,
manipulative person.
Everyone says it.
- (stammering) I don't think that I am--
- Yes, you are, Andre.
Yes, you mother (bleeping) are.
- Okay, now, now you,
like, you sound pretty angry.
- I'm not angry!
I'm not angry!
I'm fine!
I love it!
I love that you came to my house
and you broke up with me in my space
and I'm gonna think about
that every time I'm here.
That's great.
That is so perfect for me.
It's the best thing that's
ever happened to me...
- Okay, well, where else
was I supposed to do it?
'Cause you won't come to my house.
- Oh, here is!
- I wanted to--
- The puppet master is back!
- But I'm not, I'm not,
no, I'm not the puppet master.
- Why are you doing this to me?
- It's true, you won't come to my house.
You said my apartment looks
like two rats just (bleep) in it
every (bleeping) day.
- Oh, great, like, thank you for that.
I'm a bitch, thank you.
Thank you.
- I didn't call you,
no, I didn't say bitch!
I didn't, all I said was that--
- So which is it, am I
evil or am I a bitch?
- No, no, you're not
evil, Meegan, you're not--
- Well, then why are you punishing me?
- I'm not, I'm not punishing you!
I'm not--
- Oh, you broke up with me
and I'm not supposed to feel punished?
Who thinks like that?
(Andre stammering)
- I don't know, I can't,
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, okay, Meegan?
I guess I didn't think it through.
- Well, it's, like, too late now.
I mean, we're done.
- No, it's not too late.
Meegan, Meegan, seriously, I just...
Well, I... (stammering)
I had a feeling that I thought was true
and clearly, clearly it wasn't true.
- Well, I...
I'm so confused.
Like, are you breaking up with me
or are you not breaking up with me?
- Meegan!
I'm not breaking up with you!
- Okay, cool, so what do
you want to do tonight?
Like, I want to hang
out with Amy and Brad,
but maybe before that
we could go to Angelo's
and before that we can go buy some things.
(dramatic music)
- What just happened?
(upbeat music)
♪ All I want yeah ♪
♪ But I don't need yeah ♪